you posted a picture of yourself
on instagram at a photographer talk and
he sued you
he said um he said he said hey i took
that picture you owe me money yeah and
specifically um it was a the reason i
posted that one was to say like
i'm tired i wrote mood forever because
i'm covering my
face with flowers so it was kind of to
say something about you know how i felt
when the perhaps were shooting me
um and it's yeah it's um that's a that's
a thing that's a big thing that's a
great way for them to make money you
know because they they know that
settling will cost um less money than
fighting it because i've i actually am
still fighting that that um court case
it's been years and years now i think
almost three how are you feeling about
the paparazzi on one hand
you know i've never seen anybody more
covered than you by paparazzi i mean
you're you know you're always like like
it seems to me they're always there
uh but at the same point
you know then you got to put up with it
when you don't want it you can't turn it
on and off once it's in your life that's
it it was interesting last i think it
was last week or two weeks ago or
something there was nobody and my
husband was like where have they been
this is great and i was like i know
um but obviously you know this week i'm
running around promoting going on
different shows and you know where
different outfits for each show and
um they're shooting it but listen it's
it helps hopefully people will be like
oh what's she out talking about and then
maybe they'll listen to this
conversation and be interested in the
book so
um it's yeah it's a double-edged sword
um
but uh after that article came out the
the essay where um i talk about that
stuff with the paparazzi a couple of
them reached out and said listen like
there's going to be days where there are
going to be guys out front it would be
nice if you
like i'll let you post whatever you want
to post just you know give me the shot
kind of thing and so and i'll never suit
you type of thing
so it feels a little bit like making a
deal with the devil in some ways um but
now we feel a little bit you know
better having like having some of them
reach out and say like listen this is
what it is we don't want to make you
feel uncomfortable